[Musique]
tu veux quoi c'est bien ce que tu peux
cousin mais à un moment donné faut
partage des frères département qui
rappelé au quartier si moi j'ai toujours
pensé que le hip hop et le rap on avait
des choses à raconter plus forte que
dans plein d'autres milieux artistiques
tout simplement parce que en plus des
guerres internes à la musique aux labels
aux maisons de disques aux concurrences
ben le milieu du rap a quelque chose en
plus c'est la rue c'est la voyoucratie
toi si tu me donnes un paiement non je
raconte que des vrais un truc genre tu
dis n'est vraiment à 12 ans jeudi ne pas
jeter guetteur mais j'ai rien d'inventé
cetc c'est très courant dans le milieu
du rap pour des rappeurs qui viennent de
milieux sociaux plus difficile qu'ils
ont parfois été aidé par des gens qui
sont pas forcément les plus
recommandables
l'arrivée du célèbre mourir c'est là où
ça se passe donc le mounir qui fait un
peu peur à tout le monde va arriver
avoir compensation c'est moi at il payé
sa première mixtape à lui donc ça y
croit j'ai plein de projets pour lui
j'aime bien tous les personnages qui
sont durs et méchant j'aime beaucoup
entre eux beaucoup de plaisir à le faire
c'est un petit guerrier dans sa cité
snake eater n'osait y venir c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est fait tout seul qui
est dans sa tête un businessman il a pas
trop de sentiments
c'est quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup
l'argent et quand il investit il aime
bien qu'ils aient un retour 10 top hat a
mis trop tard hier il n'a pas beaucoup
d'argent situe le problème ça veut dire
que tu as mangé travers ce personnage il
a ses règles à lui et ses règles à lui
cgt et des comptes avait rien alors
maintenant kerry un peu d'oseille je
veux ma part dans son esprit à lui il
est pas méchant ce mec et il veut juste
pas se faire [ __ ] ou les baisers vous
voulez me le faire un mois durant cet
ordinateur
d'abord l'ordinateur c'est tout ce qu'il
ya là
et qu'il faut faire plaisir sur ça
et pour la petite histoire ce bureau
qu'il éclate et le vrai bureau d'olivier
mu qui est le vrai pdg d'universal
c'est vraiment son bureau quand tu votes
négatifs avec mounir tombe les cas du
positif
cros comme positif la protection et à
linverse parfois il va y avoir ce mec de
ton quartier qui t'a aidé qui va se
transformer en protecteur qui va se
transformer parfois le monde associé
puisqu'elle va être d'une aide précieuse
c'est en galère mais tu veux pas de mon
argent - cherche un pilote pour le goff
à cela quelqu'un qui me ramène de la cam
qui brasse et celle et qu'on dessine au
fond
l'heure tourne tous les plans de go fast
je suis arrivé à rotterdam pour aller
récupérer la drogue et et pouvoir
redescendre après sur paris et en fait
mon personnage et les ultra ultra d'arc
à ce moment là parce que
tout s'effondre pour la musique et sa
dernière solution qu'il a trouvée pour
faire un peu d'oseille pour pouvoir
maintenir son unité de cet art etc
c'est de se dire bon bah je vais faire
un go fast quand tu fais le fou je
compte mes gars devant l'espagne on ride
to you ça fait partie du jeu gamer c'est
la vérité
si je suis venu jusqu'ici c'est parce
que j'ai plus rien à part ça il faut
reconnaître qu'il ya un côté
complètement fascinant à le traiter en
série parce que c'est du polar quoi etc
mais c'est du polar ultra réaliste le
gunner fatah s'arrête jamais ce sens non
validé une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal